great cool this this talk is going to
focus on some I think unusual things
going to try and get at what can be
something a somewhat intimidating topic
using intuition as a sort of way
so as we're working through this
material then try and focus on building
up kind of that feeling of yes I
understand why that's true rather than
like seeing all of the steps in detail
if you possibly can so we're gonna the
title which we'll use as a jumping-off
point is how's that for size too small
too small okay great let's go bigger
okay that case I'm gonna omit the title
and jump straight to the kind of
subtitle
of which algorithm is the most efficient
so what we're gonna be thinking about is
we've got some problem and it doesn't
really matter too much what the problem
is and we've got a number of different
approaches that we could take to solve
that problem number of different
algorithms that we could use to solve
that problem and we want to choose the
most efficient one okay so we've got
several options we want to choose the
most efficient one now we'll use a
particular problem as a lens to see this
through but but really this particular
problem is not important so we're gonna
think about sorting numbers but don't
focus too much on the sorting numbers
this is just a lens to see to understand
these concepts through so our problem we
want to solve is sorting some numbers
and we've got two different approaches
that we're gonna look at that we could
use to sort some numbers and we're gonna
try and choose the most efficient
approach out of those two okay so what
do I mean by sorting numbers well let's
say I've got 4 numbers 3 4 3 2 and 1
they're currently unsorted because I
want them to be sorted from lowest to
highest ok so that's the problem we're
gonna be trying to use to look at this
through so let's let's look at our first
method for doing this
and it's called selection sort which is
just an approach to sorting some numbers
and before we do that we'll kind of
think about what we mean by the word
efficient here so what do we mean by
that well one pretty solid definition is
that efficiency equals the time
something takes to do so an algorithm
that takes longer to run is less
efficient than one that takes a less
amount of time to run that seems
reasonable and we'll start with that
definition
now let's look at selection sort the way
selection sort works it's pretty elegant
really I think is that you start with
the first number and you look through
all the numbers from that point right
and find the smallest one so we'll say
or four is the smallest one we've seen
so far then three that's smaller still
two is even smaller and one is is is is
the smallest one we've found so far and
then once you've found the smallest
number you just swap it with the number
that you started at so we'll swap four
and one
so now we've got one here and four here
so that was step one then we just move
along and we do the same process again
so we're just going to say right we'll
start with three three is the smallest
we've seen so far in this run two is
smaller still so that's the smallest
we've seen four that's not smaller than
two so we'll ignore that and so 2 is the
smallest we found and we just swap these
two numbers around and so now we've got
two and three swapped around move on to
three now we can see that those numbers
are actually already sorted but there's
no way that the processor running the
algorithm could know that so we have to
move to and carry on so now we would
start with three that's the smallest
we've seen so far look at four
let's go smaller so we we take three is
the smallest and we actually just swap
it with itself because remember we swap
the number with the number that we
started at and then for the smallest we
found so far there's no other numbers
that we can look at four we started out
so we swapped for notionally with itself
and the numbers are sorted is that that
method is called selection sort and it's
the first approach that we're going to
consider the efficiency of now let's
think about this idea of efficiency
equals time I was doing a lot of things
while we were running through that
algorithm I was talking there you know I
was kind of doing it fairly slowly in
order to illustrate it as clearly as
possible and so you could measure how
long I took to run that but it wouldn't
be a great measure because there would
be so many kind of conflated factors
that went into that final result for how
good is selection sort so we're not
going to use time because it's not
actually a perfect approach but a
different approach we could think about
is how many things we had to do how many
steps we had to take to sort that so
let's run that algorithm again but
thinking about steps this time
okay so let's take those numbers again
so we'll mix em up a bit I don't know
we're gonna have three one four and two
or something and we're gonna focus on
the steps we have to do this time so
first of all and that first run-through
I had to say is three the smallest yes
it is is once more than that yes it is
it's possible and that no it's too
smaller than that one no so you could
kind of see that as four steps there and
then I had to do the final part of that
run through which is to swap this number
I started with with the smallest number
that I found so I have to swap three and
one and you could see that as a fifth
step that I have to do in that run but
I'm actually gonna say we're not going
to we're going to ignore that fifth step
and we'll talk about why we can ignore
it later okay so let's move on then we
have to do three for two so three is the
smaller so far then for no smaller to
all that is smaller so we'd kind of did
three steps to do that so we swap two
and three and we kind of felt like we
had to do three steps because we had to
do three checks for which is the
smallest number okay then we move on to
four we have to say okay four is a small
or so far yes three is smaller than that
great that felt like two steps we swap
them over or a we ignore the swap step
for now I'll explain why later and then
we have to do just a kind of bookkeeping
for just mainly for simplicity's sake
for is the smallest we found so far
we swap it with itself and we're done
okay so we've kind of got maybe some
rough sort of horse sense of the number
of steps that it took to run that
algorithm and it feels it feels more
precise than that than that idea of just
saying time so maybe we'll accept that
now we're gonna say efficiency we're not
going to measure that by the amount of
time
we're gonna measure it by the number of
steps okay so that's our new measure of
efficiency now let's think about these
steps here so there's there's ten steps
here so for an input length of four with
four numbers then we have to do ten
steps so we've got our first measure of
efficiency which is pretty cool let's
think about if we had some more numbers
so what about if we had five numbers
well we could probably just kind of you
know using maybe a bit of intuition just
to say what I feel like using my
pattern-matching brain it would just be
another row down here right so we could
maybe just kind of accept that it's a
little bit loosey-goosey but often
intuition is and that's absolutely fine
so it's another row there so to do five
and input lengths of five numbers to
sort five numbers we have to do an extra
five steps so that's 15 steps all right
let's just let's just press on with this
so 6 it's gonna be another row again and
then seven it's gonna be another row
again and then we'll go up to eight one
final row so we've kind of got this sort
of a sense maybe a little bit of a sense
of how this grows as the input grows and
maybe more powerfully we could start
thinking about well what if I have a
certain input length that's a nymph or
length of 50 how many steps is that
going to be we don't want to have to run
the algorithm to find out we won't have
some way of taking the input lengths and
then producing the number of steps
that's going to take and we can maybe do
it a little bit here because this is a
triangle and there's a fairly well
understood progression of numbers of
triangular numbers so we could actually
probably just find the fiftieth
triangular number and away we go I know
that would be fine don't know the
fiftieth triangle number anyone know
okay that's fine what about if I said a
triangle is a bit like a square
does anyone know the 50th square number
that might be easier to calculate yeah
one was I'm sorry 500 okay God sounds
good to me okay great so if we had an
influx of 50 then we sort of feel like
it would take about 2,500 steps is
that's a pretty powerful idea we've got
now we can take any input length and we
know how good or rather in this case bad
selection sort is going to be so we've
got this idea of a square to do that
with now we're being really
loosey-goosey here so I sort of asked
you to just accept that we would not
mark the step that it took in each run
to swap the two numbers at the end of
the run and now I'm asking you to
swallow something really really
ridiculous which is not only are we just
kind of being fairly loosey-goosey with
this triangle where I'm also taking
hate's of triangles sort of like a
square let's just go over the square
because it's easier and that seems even
more silly and hopefully you'll just
bear with me for a bit longer and I'll
talk about why that's why that's okay
because it certainly makes things easier
and I think possibly gets at the truth a
little bit more too which is currency
cool so we've got this idea of selection
sort
it's our method for sorting these
numbers and we've got an idea of how
efficient it is roughly in terms of the
number of steps but I feel like we're
not quite there yet
let's get even more intuitive
cuz I'm gonna graph number of sets here
and then input legs here
remember that's just a number of numbers
that we have to sort so we've got a few
a few few entries here already so I'm
wiggling uh from 0 to 32 there so I'll
just mark in the divisions and then
we're gonna go from here up to about 250
steps so I'm marking the hundreds
roughly and we're being pretty pretty
vague about this and that's absolutely
fine
okay that's a little bit lower it's
actually
okay so we've got a graph here input
length along here so it could be 8 or 16
or whatever and the number of steps that
we need to do that sort all right
let's mark in and we've got some
empirical values here that we can mark
in right away so 4 we decided with 16
steps 4 times 4 so I'll mark that in and
then 8 we kind of decided was 8 times 8
steps which is one more time thank you
grants great 64 so again being pretty
loosey-goosey and that's all good and
then 16 16 times 16 is too fine to take
out a calculator it's absolutely fine
we've all got computers in our pockets
20:56 thank you
brilliant ok so that person's right at
the top of this graph okay so why are we
doing this well first of all it's kind
of cool to do scraps of empirical
numbers that we've figured out but
second of all it's actually showing us a
much more powerful idea about this this
is the efficiency of this algorithm
which is that it has a shape that we can
graph and so we can kind of get that's
not a very good line but we can kind of
get a sense of what happens as you do
more and more inputs so these isolated
numbers they were sort of useful
definitely but you get them by graphing
it you get a sense of where this is
going and it's going straight into the
roof it's going it's gonna be by the
time we if we could graph this all the
way to the roof it would be it would
seem vertical at that point used to be
like you add a tiny bit more import it's
way worse way faster so and this is
really powerful because we can now
understand the step growth which is
actually the most powerful measure that
will look at for efficiency
so we're gonna go two steps and we're
gonna focus on step growth and it's for
two reasons first of all we can see how
bad things can get in really extreme
cases so we can get a sense that if you
have quite a lot of input then you are
going to have a gargantuan number of
steps and second we can see how this
grows which means we can compare two
different algorithms so when we were
just looking at isolated sets of steps
so let's say Oh for an input length of
four then at sixteen steps for an input
length of eight that's 64 steps it will
be tough to compare two different
approaches to different algorithms
because you know you don't really get a
sense of how much better or worse one is
whereas if we've got an idea of step
growth here we're really gonna be able
to we're really gonna be able to see how
much better or worse each one is if we
can get another line on this graph so
let's do that
let's look at our second measure
remember we don't really care about
sorting algorithms or anything like that
it's just a tool that we can use so that
we can understand these ideas so focus
on the concepts like step growth
okay so merge sort is another way that
you can use to sort numbers so let's
take our numbers again it's 4 3 2 1
we're gonna sort these using a different
approach merge sort now if we take a
list of thing forgetting about that list
for a second if we just take a list for
just one item in it with the number 3 in
it how long is it going to take to sort
that list
one more time two steps okay could be
two steps yeah absolutely
any uh any other thoughts using any
approach you like how many steps do we
do
I would say it's zero steps because
there's only one number in it so it has
to already be sorted take any number any
list with one number in it and you know
it's already sorted
there's no it can't be out of order with
itself yeah exactly zero exactly zero
step so let's take another list with
with with just one number in it five
it's already sorted we know that okay
now this is pretty powerful idea
because if we take one list with one
number in it and then we take another
list with another with with one other
number it so now we've got two lists
here this isn't for a list of four and
three this is a list of four and then a
list of three we can combine these two
lists merge them if you will using a
pretty simple process so all we do is
we've got two lists and we just take the
smaller number that we're on from each
list okay so four and three are our two
candidates the smaller of those is three
so we take three and then we've got
nothing left in this list so we just
compare which is take four because
that's the only thing that we can take
and now we've got a sorted list
all right so we started with two sorted
lists just with one number in each and
then we combined them to produce a new
sorted list that was double the length
and it only took two steps to do it
alright let's see another example let's
start with a with a list of four items
okay so four and three we're gonna do
the same thing again we're just gonna
say okay well we just choose the lowest
one out of our two options and that's
three and then we choose the lowest one
out of four and nothing we can't nothing
to choose here so it must be for do the
same again with this list with these two
lists so choose the lowest one it's one
choose the lowest one out of two and
nothing got nothing left in this list to
choose and that's two and then the
beauty is we can do it again okay so one
three and one choose the lowest one
that's one now we move along to two now
we'd compare two and three so we take
two we're at the end of that list so
we're done so we just take three and
we're there it's certainly under the
list so we take four and our list is
sorted
that's called merge sort and it's I
think extremely beautiful let's try
another example let's take I don't know
for three but let's pretend that we've
already done the merging of these two
lists earlier
okay so we're actually combining two
lists of two so we take the smallest of
four and two that's to take the smallest
of four and one
that's one take the smallest of four and
nothing that's four take the smallest of
three and nothing
that's three now that list is not sorted
so something's gone wrong and as she
went wrong at the previous step when we
set these two was sorted they weren't
sorted 4 is bigger than 3 and 2 is
bigger than 1 so you have to make much
sort work you have to start with sorted
lists but it's ok because you always
just start with sorted lists of one item
each which is why this concept of a
single item this being already sorted is
so powerful so things went wrong here
because those two lists weren't sorted
but things went right here because we
started with four individual lists there
sorted so we're always gonna keep on
combining into new sorted lists okay
that's how merge sort works now the
question that we actually care about is
how many steps does it take to run now
this one when we just had two items in
our in our overall list we decided while
we had to do compare four and three that
was one step and then we had to compare
four and nothing that was two steps so
the total total number of steps to sort
two items was just two steps four four
items we had to compare four and three
then we had to compare for and nothing
so that was two steps then we were to
compare two and one and then compared to
nothing so that was another two steps so
it's four steps to get from this layer
down to this layer and then for these
ones then it was again we were to
compare one and three to get one and
then we had to compare two and three got
two and then we had to compare three and
nothing got three and then four nothing
got four so that was another four steps
to get down there let's do eight
okay so well we'll kind of move through
a little more quickly here so we know
we're gonna get seven and eight out of
this we're gonna get five and six out of
this we're gonna have three and four out
of that and we're gonna get one and two
out of that keep going
then we're gonna get five six seven
eight out of that one two three four out
of that one more layer we know the list
is one two three four five six seven
eight
now probably we can take a little bit of
a guess and say if we had to do two
steps on each level for a list of two
and four steps on each level for a list
of four how many steps are we going to
do on each level for a list of eight
yeah absolutely I agree okay so we're
just gonna fill in 8 8 8 here so we've
now got a relation between the infant
lengths and a number of steps that are
gonna be required again it's pretty
vague we're basically drawing out trees
and kind of talking about layers and
stuff like that if you want to get into
the details of that there is some
interesting maths to understand that
more deeply but a kind of a rudimentary
level we can maybe get a bit of a sense
for it that the more input you have the
more layers you're gonna have and the
more input you have the more steps
you're gonna have to do per layer we
have to get any more precise than that
that's absolutely fine for us and we
also handily got some it's got some new
specific values that we can graph so for
a list of length 2 we know we have to do
two steps that puts us way down here for
a list of length 4 we're gonna have to
do 4 steps plus 4 steps is 8 steps still
pretty low for a list of eight we're
gonna do 8 plus 8 plus 8 it's 24 steps
now here's where the fun starts that's
way too high sorry here's where the fun
starts
what about 16 how many steps is that
gonna be any thoughts let's draw it okay
yeah that sounds interesting to me
okay sweets that we had ate before right
so it's 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
is the next one we're going to try and
do
now I'm I could carry on drawing that
and that might be fun for us all but I'm
gonna ask us to go a bit further and say
if we added a level so we added one
extra level to the tree to move from
here to here so we doubled the input
from two to four and we had to do one
more layer and then we doubled the input
from four to eight and we had to do
another layer on top of that so if we
double the input on from eight to
sixteen I think we can probably just
guess that we're going to do just one
more layer to get there and we know that
the rule is is that we just take the
input length as the number of steps we
have to do per layer so if we have to do
three layers here and I'm gonna guess we
have to do four layers here so that's
gonna be four layers times 16 which is
thank you for thank you okay so it's 64
now what about 32 mm let's just let's
just use this relation five times
thirty-two anyone thank you brilliant
okay so that puts us up here okay so
right away we can see which is gonna be
the more efficient algorithm for our
measure of step growth okay so this is
the one we just did it's much short and
this is selection
okay so we've got our so for which
algorithm we should choose its merge
sort it's much much much more efficient
this is going up way more slowly now
it's kind of cool now I asked you to
just kind of indulge me a bit on why we
can ignore the swap step on selection
sort and why we can just kind of say
it's kind of like a square isn't it a
triangle even though that pretty much
doubles the number of steps you know
kind of makes selection sort look
considerably worse than it actually is
and I kind of asked you to just accept
that well I think we can talk a bit
about why that's okay now let's imagine
that instead of being saying selection
sort is twice as worse we had some magic
that meant that we could divide the
number of steps by a million for
selection sort so no matter what input
lengths you send into selection sort you
can divide that number of steps by
million let's just say we found some
amazing algorithm that allowed you to do
that which doesn't exist but let's just
say we did so we're kind of giving
selections for all the help we possibly
can by dividing the number of steps by a
fixed number and that's crucial fixed
number so the number of steps we divide
by does not change relate it in relation
to the input length we can always just
divide by million let's think about what
would happen so I'm just going to draw a
mini version of this graph so here's
merge tour I'll draw that in kind of
goes up like that pretty slowly but but
everybody going up and then selection
sort because of our divided by million
when the early input length is when the
input length is quite low we're
basically down here like you can't even
see the line it's just it's just it's
just runs along the grid line because
divided by million reduces the number of
steps by an awful lot but slowly as the
input length goes up and up and up that
divided by million will become less and
less significant and then you'll see
that lines start to creep up and what's
sort of fascinating is that it will
start to look like the original line
before we divided it by a million and
eventually
it will cross that merge short line and
be worse than it and it will go back to
being really really bad all the time
forever and so that's why we don't care
about these kind of petty divisions
these call constant factors if you want
to look this up it's why we don't care
about them because though they help at
the beginning in the long run which
remember was what we care about we care
about the extreme cases because we're
trying to write scalable algorithms and
we care about how the steps grow over
the long case over the long term because
we care about those things those
constant factors we just ignore them
they're not relevant okay so hopefully
that's an explanation for why we're not
so worried about things like this
triangle and vs. square thing so let's
summarize what where we got to so we
said that initially efficiency equals
time and that was that was somewhat
helpful I was ok but it had this problem
of it kind of depends on processor speed
so if you run this on a slow processor
let's say I'm slower than my friend bill
at running this section sort algorithm
then it makes selection thought look
worse than it is
seems a bit loosey goosey we're not
we're not so we're not so happy about
that so we moved to efficiency equal
steps that was better that was
definitely better but it kind of had
this problem of you only got isolated
values so you could kind of with steps
you could say oh if you have an
intellect before then the number of
steps is 16 or if you have an input
length of 8 the number of steps is 64
she's kind of useful but we don't really
what we really care about is that how
think how bad things are going to get in
there extreme cases so steps wasn't so
useful so eventually we moved to this
idea of efficiency equal step growth and
that allows us to compare algorithms as
we were able to do here comparing
selection sort of selection sort and
merge sort and it also allowed us to say
what are the extreme cases like
and what's really cool about this is
that all of these ideas work for code so
when you're writing some program to do
something you can use these concepts and
transfer them directly to find which if
you're considering several approaches
which one you should choose based on
which is the most efficient and if you
want to learn more about that then you
can look up two things number one is
algorithmic complexity
and the other is asymptotic notation
Thanks
I guess I have a bit of time for
questions any questions
yeah
so the question is how would you
determine the efficiency of something
that where the implementation had
already been done for you and you maybe
didn't even have access to the code yeah
really good question um there's a few
approaches you can do first of all you
can actually do an empirical approach
you can just literally just run it and
see what happens over a bunch of
different cases and often you only have
to do really so let's say it was a
sorting algorithm you were trying to
test so let's say you were trying to say
how efficient is the JavaScript sorting
algorithm that's built into node for
example then you could just create a
bunch of different arrays of different
sizes run the sorting algorithm on them
time how long each one takes and then
just graph them and you get a pretty
good idea so that that would be okay oh
but it would actually be sort of the
antithesis of sort of what we've talked
about here actually because it's a super
empirical and and not looking at trying
to develop a relation for that
efficiency another approach you can use
is is just is to read the source code if
it's available to you because probably
it will implement some well-known
algorithm that you can figure out and
then crucially let's say it's not
sorting it's something that isn't a well
studied phenomenon for how to write the
most efficient version of words then you
can actually just read the code and
using some reasonably simple techniques
that unfortunately I didn't have time to
get into here today you can translate
the code into a representation of steps
so you can just say oh this let's say
100 lines of code I can figure out how
many steps it's gonna take for some
input and then I can use that too and I
won't go too far into this but basically
to produce some sort of function and I
mean that in the mathematical sense that
will output effectively a graph
basically so there's different growth
orders
they're called orders of growth so some
orders of growth are called something
like let's say quadratic which looks
something like that there's other orders
of growth that are called logarithmic
that looks sort of like
and then there's let's say factorial
growth which you know really rocket
straight up and so on and there's a few
well understood orders of growth that
you'll be able to fit that algorithm
that you analyzed into and just
instantly tell okay how good or bad is
this yeah
thanks really really nice question any
other questions yeah
that's a fantastic question the quote
the question is how is how is it step to
find Loosli is the short answer
roughly speaking it often corresponds to
a very simple programmatic operation so
for example you probably say that one
plus one is one step if you take a loop
so something that you know does
something a bunch of times you probably
say assuming that let's say let's say
this is a loop through a list you would
probably say the length of that list is
the number of steps that will be
represented in here give it a bit of
practice there's just a few different
types of form in code that will produce
a certain number of steps so there's a
single operation which is one step
there's a loop which is a group of steps
and then there's that's a nested loop
which would be a group of a group of
steps and so on
and you'll if you practice a few if you
know there's literature about this
online that will walk you through this
process there's some good stuff on Khan
Academy about this for example it just
becomes a sort of a skill that you
practice after a few hours you'll just
be able to do it I don't know how much
more time we have for questions Sara any
more questions
yeah
that's a wonderful question the question
is once you have some code how do you
find a better way to implement a more
efficient way to implement that same
that's sought to solve that same problem
that is kind of you know that the quite
the like that I guess life's question
itself really the short answer is it's
like any kind of problem-solving
discipline where you learn different
techniques for making things better
basically
so for example one technique that's
really really nice is saying do I have
the right data structure to represent
the things that I'm storing so just that
maybe we'll go into this super quickly
but if I want to let's say I've got a
list of numbers and it's like I've got
three five four five two five one four
or something like notice that some of
the numbers are repeated and I want to
find out I want to get a list of the
number of repetitions of each number
inside here so three appears once five I
think appears three times four appears
twice and so on let's say I want that's
what the problem I want to solve if I
use the right data structure
representation just to as I as I as I
look at this data I will be able to
solve this problem way more quickly than
if I use the wrong one and so one
technique for getting better at writing
more efficient algorithms is to learn
more about data structures so you know
the kind of I guess TL DR and this one
is if you use a hash to solve this
problem you will end up with a much more
efficient solution so that's I would say
that's one thing it's a broad topic and
if you want to learn more about it
especially around algorithms there's a
ton of stuff online because very often
this stuff comes off as interview
questions companies and so there are a
lot of people who will who will sell you
guides
to tell you show you how to get better
at this technique okay
all right we'll do that thanks so much
everyone thanks for coming
[Applause]